It's one of the first
things we look for,
when searching for new life.
And it's essential
to sustaining our own.
We know there's water on Mars.
But without much
atmospheric pressure,
♪♪
It doesn't behave
the way you think.
I'm Wrenn Schmidt,
and we're exploring
the science behind
"For All Mankind."
Because water is essential
to a future on Mars,
we wanted to explore
what it would take
for Ed, Kelly
and the Mars
crew to actually
extract water
on the red planet.
[clicks]
Let's start with Mars' surface.
It's not particularly...
habitable.
Water requires
pressure to stay liquid.
Unlike Earth who's atmosphere
creates the pressure necessary
to give us lakes and oceans.
Mars barely has an atmosphere.
♪♪
So, it's surface is
devoid of liquid water.
Ice and gas can exist on
the low pressure surface,
but to find water in it's liquid
life sustaining form,
you'll have to dig deep...
where the weight of the ground
above creates more pressure.
And it's this
difference in pressure,
above versus below.
That makes extracting
that water tricky.
As the liquid can
turn suddenly,
and dangerously to steam.
Welcome to Valles Marineris.
The Grand Canyon of Mars.
Where scientists have
recently discovered
high levels of hydrogen.
It's here..
that in the show the Soviets
detect a large under ground lake
using ground penetrating radar
and team up with
Helios to drill.
Ed and the team know
that the deeper they drill,
the more pressure
they'll need underground.
If they don’t match this
increasing pressure,
the water will
convert to steam,
expand and shoot up
through the hole.
So they pump CO2
into the drill casing
maintaining a
pressure equilibrium.
But when they fail
to maintain that balance
and the drill
penetrates the reservoir.
The drop in pressure makes
all that water turn to steam
and rush up.
[sound of steam pipe]
[sound of explosion]
NASA's official Mars strategy
is to follow the water.
If we're going to make
life there viable for us,
we'll need a water source.
We'll need to maintain the
proper balance
when we access it.
And make
sure we aren't
disturbing another life,
potentially thriving
in the water
just beneath the surface.
♪♪